and so what you learn um looking at you
know two
250 years of technology evolution
is um the number of times that society
has successfully stopped
innovation of technology is zero
[Music]
brett king thank you for joining me
today how are you all the way from
bangkok thailand
i'm very well thanks for having me um
yeah i'm uh
stuck in a quarantine hotel here in
bangkok
um waiting so that i can get out uh
to to my apartment that i've got here
once i clear quarantine
wow it's definitely a crazy crazy time
but you know
start talking about crazy times let's go
even a crazier time
talk to me that's about the time that
you had an engine failure and you had to
certain and you had to manage that
yeah yeah it was a few years ago now i
started
learning to fly when i was um 20
um i had always wanted to be a pilot i
thought my
um you know corrected vision excluded me
from from being a commercial pilot at
least but i got my private pilot's
license
um when i was uh in my uh yeah i guess
you know latter half of the year year
when i was 20.
um and then um you know started to
incorporate that in my business so
i did i had my own software company
after a while
this is about 93
and i would you know fly around
providing software support for companies
around the uh the province
or state of victoria in australia where
i was living at the time
and um um you know
it was a great way to get hours and and
get some flying experience i was flying
out
to a a place called mount gambia
on the eastern side of victoria
i was in a single engine
piper warrior which is a four-seat
single-engine aircraft
at about 7000 feet um
and you you have four fuel tanks in this
aircraft you have
wingtip tanks and then the primary main
wing tanks
and the the um technique is to
essentially run the tank almost dry
where you start to feel the engine um
you know starve or fuel and then you
switch over so you use as much fuel as
possible in the tank
so i was going from the right uh tip
tank to the left tip tank
the engine started to uh um you know
just
uh cough and splutter a little bit as
it does and then i switched over the
left tank and
it coughed and splatted a bit more and
then stopped
um but you know one of the
one of the things about flight training
in terms of discipline
is that you have these um checklists
that you're constantly
practicing on and so you have an engine
failure checklist and and so i
immediately went into the checklist
the guy that was sitting next to me in
the aircraft was starting to panic
and i was just like okay mixture-ish
master on
fuel on you're going through the process
and in that
i discovered that the fuel selector
switch which i used to select the tank
was loose and it was showing that it was
on the left
tank but it was actually in the off
position because of that
looseness so i selected another tank and
the engine fired up again so it was
still wind um you know it was still
being
uh you know as i was sort of descending
it was still being driven by the wind
and as soon as some fuel got into the
engine and bang it fired up again in the
process i'd lost uh
um you know a couple of thousand feet um
i had already selected a potential
landing site and been
done through that um you know so yeah so
um
you know they say you have one of those
uh for every 18
000 hours of flying time so i think
that's my engine failure for life pretty
much
but um i also had an alternator failure
in a cessna 210 flying between tasmania
um and um moorabbin um in melbourne
and which is the largest general
aviation
airport in the southern hemisphere and i
was flying over
water and i had an alternator failure um
well
you know i i managed to turn everything
off um
you know before i you know had the
complete battery
failure i navigated just using you know
maps and compass
to you know moorabbin where i had to
land switched it on
just had enough power just to get the
radio call in
for air traffic control to get clearance
to land
and then the the power went completely
out so i had to
the cessna 210 was a retractable gear
aircraft so i had to
manually pump the gear down before i
could land so that was another fun one
but that's it that's that's all i that's
that's it
so so so besides those exhilarating
moments
brad you're and you know a phenomenal
speaker a keynote speaker worldwide i
believe in over
50 countries with tedx wired at texas
and hillary university and and more
you're the host of breaking banks the
number one fintech radio show with over
six and a half million listeners so
after this i'm gonna need a couple of
pointers how do i get past that that
thousand mark
but you are also a great thinker
and futurist what i think you call it
and and you wrote some really phenomenal
books
augmented go ahead
that's right go ahead you wrote some
phenomenal books like
like banking 4.0 and augmented and and
you have some
really interesting thoughts behind you
know the the
the where we're going in terms of
financially where we're going in terms
of our you know interactions
and so what i'd love to do in these next
13 minutes or so i'd really love to pick
your brain
on these different subjects i'd love to
hear from you what are some of the key
answers you have
as to our financial institute financial
institutions not just in one place in
the world but you know globally and
where we're headed for that
what what is augmented for you and and
what are some of the most exciting
things we can expect in terms of
consumer behavior shift
from your perspective in the coming
decade or so
you know this this is um going to be
probably the most interesting decade
um to live through in all of human
history thus far i think
um the reason being is
um obviously we've got a lot of things
happening um the impact of climate
change
um you know we we have uh
you know covert a major pandemic that
we're having to deal with
it's not over yet and it won't be over
for some time
um you know we may live have to live
with covert uh you know for for many
years
um it will weaken uh obviously but um
you know we're gonna have to have
modified behavior but the big
um the big factor uh
mystery factor is of course artificial
intelligence and what that does
to the world and so high levels of
automation that creates high levels of
unemployment
but creates massive affluence and wealth
you know um at the same time for many
um you know it's it's a real quandary
how do we
um navigate that evolution of human
behavior where
work is hot you know becomes highly
automated you know you don't have
human robots you know just following
processes anymore because
we we use algorithms and um you know and
and robots to do that stuff
and so the role of work itself is going
to change pretty dramatically over the
next 10 20 years
um and um you know that changes the way
we think about
money and assets and so forth as well so
um you know we're talking about a
uh sort of the next level of human
consciousness as a you know from a
societal perspective
and having to adapt to to some pretty
significant
um global changes so when you're talking
about you know
different levels of human consciousness
when we talk about different levels of
interacting with money so we've already
obviously in the past few decades we've
seen a dramatic you know
shift in consumer behavior i think that
to before if you talk 10 years ago when
you said banking
you had to differentiate between banking
and digital banking today i think
banking
already is you know it's considered a
pretty worldwide it is digital
and and so people are now looking at the
different verticals that are going to be
revolutionized in a similar way that
that banking has been
where do you see financial institutions
going from here
now that we've reached this sort of you
know
acceptable state where we where we don't
have to go to to banks anymore
what is the next step and and i'd love
to specifically dive
into what you were writing about in
banking 4.0
sure so um the biggest shift here is the
way
we will interact with our bank account
um right now
our bank account is essentially a dumb
passive artifact
you know right um it doesn't even give
you your
bank balance you know when you take a
debit card into a store you know you you
just uh
it allows you to transact right um but
you know we're
we're we've seen since 2018
a pretty dramatic shift in the way
people use
their day-to-day discretionary spending
and so
if you look at um uh
you know the use of mobile wallets you
know
obviously it's peaked in china or it's
it's blown up in china in a good way
you know alipay 10 cent wechat pay but
you know kenya and pacer paytm in india
et cetera um cacao in south korea
the use of mobile wallets um in 2020 was
effectively double that of plastic cards
both debit cards and credit cards
globally wow
um and so this is probably something
most people you know in
in you know the geographies that we tend
to live in like the us
israel and so forth are not familiar
with they they think they their
plastic cards are the way people do
day-to-day banking
the the difference of course it's going
to emerge between
smart mobile wallets or cloud-based
mobile wallets that where we do our
discretionary spending is that they're
starting to get a level of intelligence
around coaching us in our money
making sure that we have access to
credit when and where we need it
and helping us save and become
financially healthier over time
that differentiate them um significantly
from
the dumb artifacts of uh you know
plastic cards paper checks and
and um yeah and even cash and so
that's the big difference from a banking
perspective that your bank account will
become a smart companion that
coaches you and helps you with your
money and this is even more critical
coming off the back of coronavirus so
that people have the tools to
recover economically from um the effects
of coven
so do you see the primary differentiator
of where we're headed in
in the very next phase to be more of
this interactive
consultant personalized consultant for
every
for every bank account is is that what
we're saying and i believe that that is
also what you're
what you're also passionately working
working with moving and you've raised
quite a bit of sum of money to to go and
make that positive impact
so is that really the next big milestone
that you're observing
well we've been working on this for 10
years you know the move-in smart bank
account technology
and um today our technology has already
achieved some pretty significant
milestones in that respect if you use
our technology move in
um you know on average month on month
compared with someone who doesn't use
movement
you're saving about five to eight
percent per month
or you know extra this is just because
of the fact that we're giving you
awareness of how you use your money and
with more effective awareness about that
you make better decisions and so
um you know that's that's the core i
guess
contribution we've made to the financial
services space
in in that time so how does that
actually interact with you know where
we're headed with artificial
intelligence and
the milestones of you know relieving us
of a lot of those decision
decision-making processes
given that you know we'll have well
we'll have other entities that might
know
better for us what will make us happier
what products we would want or need or
what food we should consume or not
consume
so how does that whole thing play out as
you're looking into the
into into a world that is really filled
with artificial intelligence
well it you know it it it happens not
just in respect to sort of coaching you
and helping you with money see how you
you save but
also anticipating your needs so you know
for example
we understand your cash flow so we can
predict uh
90 days out if your current cash flow is
going to result in a shortfall
if you know you're going to get to the
point where um you know you can't pay
your car insurance bill or your
rent or or something like that we'll be
able to warn you in advance and so
then we'll give you tactics for how you
could uh you know
handle handle that disparity or you know
let's say a more practical example you
know you walk into a grocery store
and we know that you normally spend
three hundred dollars on your groceries
today you've only got two hundred
dollars in your
account um you know what would normally
happen is you'd get to the checkout
you'd swipe your card and it would be
declined because you don't have
sufficient balance
and then you have to figure out how
you're going to pay for your groceries
so we wouldn't have that you know
when you walk in the grocery store we'd
say hey it looks like you you need a
little bit of extra cash for your
grocery shopping today
we can give you 100 the fee for that is
five dollars would you like to proceed
yes or no and
the problem is solved you don't have to
sign an application form for a credit
card
you don't have to wait for that card to
arrive in the mail um you know you can
just solve that problem as you walk in
the store and so that sort of
contextualization of financial services
is
what the technology is really doing for
us right now there's two elements to
that one is it's
lowering the friction right it's taking
all of the rules and the friction that
you have associated with banks today
sign this piece of paper will push it
through the approval process kyc
etc you know and it's solving that in a
much more elegant
manner because of experience design and
technology
and uh you know secondly it's starting
to put some positive friction back in
there around
financial health financial well-being
and and helping you save money
now that makes a lot of sense and and
obviously the more you're
sitting with the consumer the more
you're interacting with with the
consumer on a daily basis and not
necessarily
you know right now this this whole
operation of what you're saying is
pretty much run through the credit score
right
at least in the united states where you
have these the different entities that
are you know monitoring it they're
getting some
you know this like very fragmented
pieces of information trying to piece
together that your quality as a consumer
and as a spender and the likelihood of
if a bank will give you a loan that
you'll be able to repay but when you're
talking about these micro loans
on these macro decision making points
you have insight into
you know their inc their their spending
and their
their income on pretty much on a minute
by minute basis and so your predictions
can be obviously
much more valuable talk to me a little
bit about augmented we just have a few
minutes but i'd love to
you know get excited with you about
where are we headed what are some of the
most exciting things that possibly we
can experience
you know and what can my niece what can
i be excited about my niece experiencing
she's six now
when she'll be 26 sure
four major changes you know or four
major
innovation themes over the next uh 10 or
20 years the first is
obviously artificial intelligence so you
know we we talk about that we talk about
three levels of ai development where
we're currently at machine learning deep
learning
then we talk about artificial general
intelligence and then you know hyper
intelligent
ai secondly experience design so this is
where technology is infused or that
intelligence is infused into
society through a range of technologies
smart glasses and
um smart speakers are sort of emerging
right now
um but you know you'll have sensors in
your body that you know track your
health and so forth and that'll be part
of that the third layer is health tech
you know driven by the pandemic but also
driven by
um you know improvements in
understanding of uh sort of the
the system uh genome uh edit
genomic editing um you know better
sensors your
your smart devices will know when you're
sick before you will
and then finally um and putting it all
together
you know the emergence of smart
economies and smart infrastructure and
the way
economies will compete in the future
will be on the
the level of technology including
renewables
and climate mitigation carbon
sequestration
and all of these technologies that will
lead to better societies in the future
so they're the four major
uh trends that uh where technology is
really going to change the way
um society operates and the way we live
live with these technologies
right so so just like most startups i'm
saying this is a marketplace
and where you have on one hand you have
the people that are the innovators
they're the people who are pushing this
forward they're excited about the
technology
and they they they study that and they
dedicate pretty much
their time and their life to that but
then you have the people that
are dedicated in your life to regulate
things right and to make sure that
things are in order and we don't just
make rash decisions
that will harm our society later on and
a lot of these times these things are
clashing right and
we're seeing this with autonomous
vehicles with drone deliveries
with a lot of health tech startups
that's really the big barrier
for technology and you know we've seen
this in the news every day with with the
vaccine approval
how is that is that going to change in
the coming years are people going to
adapt more to innovation are people
going to hold back a little bit more in
your opinion
so yeah um you know look um
this is the to be a good futurist you
have to study the the past
you know you have to study history right
and you have to be a good pastist you
know
and so what you learn um looking at you
know two
250 years of technology evolution
is um the number of times that society
has successfully stopped
innovation of technology is zero
right it just never happened and so um
you know this debate we have about
artificial intelligence and whether it's
going to affect society whether we
should allow it as an example
this is a mistake um you know we should
spend
far more time thinking about how it's
going to change
our lives and thinking about smart ways
to transition to that new state so when
we talk about
this permissive versus precautionary
views from a regulatory perspective what
we
see right now for example in the united
states is that
you know in the financial services space
you've got heavy regulation
that is a precautionary and has
restricted
fintechs in the market and med tech as
well health tech
comparative to china which has had a
more permissive regulatory environment
and as a result
on the fintech space alone china is
seven to ten years ahead of the united
states today because of that
regulatory burden in the us and so
regulation that is a precautionary
that tends to regulate before a
technology is known
in terms of what it impacts versus
regulating
in real time as those effects become
seen
tends to restrict or
slow down innovation in those specific
markets and so
if if we're going to advance as a
species
we have to get used to the fact that as
a species we're constantly innovating
we're constantly creating new technology
and we have to just get much better at
long-term planning as to how those
changes should be managed at a societal
level for example
you know um you know if you're if you're
likely to lose your job
then what are we going to do about it as
a result of ai
right a hundred percent uh brad i think
these are these are fascinating
questions
uh i think that i got a chance to to
look at the other different books that
you've written and i think that
at the end one of the one of the most
important things that a young
entrepreneur can do these days
is be a futurist or an amateur futurist
and and
mainly both get excited about it be
cynical about it be
cautious be worried but but at the end
be exhilarate have that exhilarating
feeling that
you know we are going to be a part of
the most interesting decades ever that's
ever happened and
and each of us can decide you know what
are the things we want to work on what
are the most meaningful innovations that
will propel
the humanity forward and you know i'm
now that i'm thinking about whatever
you know companies i would want to
create i've been telling people that you
know maybe i want to create a company
that
is responsible for inserting the chips
that will monitor for heart disease and
for
heart attacks and well test our blood
because you know it's it's inevitably
inevitably it's going to happen
as an amateur futurist i i know it's
going to happen the question is
who will will the person doing it be
responsible enough to do it properly
and to do it transparently and i think
that one of the scariest things for me
is
that the future it's we don't know who's
going to be owning the future
uh and who would what what who what
innovators what private companies
and so i just hope that it's responsible
people and i think that that's something
that we've been learning over this past
decade so brett thank you for coming on
this show i really appreciate it
the last question i have welcome three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
oh cool
um thinker persistent
and optimistic wonderful
i love it brett thank you very very much
stay safe and stay healthy and enjoy
thailand
thank you very much